[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en attendant que cette souris ressorte
je vais vous raconter une histoire
extrêmement touchante
chaque fois que je la raconte je me
bouleverse moi même c'est que je suis un
grand sensible
delphine et marinette de revenus et de
faire des commissions pour leurs parents
il y avait dans leurs cabas trois
morceaux de savon un pain de sucre d'une
fraise de veau et pour 15 sous de clous
de girofle tu les villas mais la leyre
gentil ça ne remplace pas méthane
période d'un chien d'un vague mais a
perdu son envie
non c'est moi l'aveuglent c'est triste
tu devrais prendre énorme quand une idée
[Musique]
voici
mais dites moi d'abord ce qu'il y a dans
votre panier ça sans répondre non non
répond d'abord dans l'histoire oui je
vous dirais qu'avant d'être aveugle moi
même j'étais déjà au service d'un homme
aveugle
il me tenait au bout d'une longue
ficelle pour que nous ayons tous les
deux l'illusion de moins dépendre l'un
de l'autre je le conduisais partout et
chansons fleury d'aude et bein je lui a
dit qu'elle est faire nous on risquait
de nous donner à manger
bref je lui rendais toutes sortes de
services sans parler du plaisir qu'il
prenait à m'écouter
je ne suis qu'un chien c'est entendu
mais parler fait toujours passer le
temps tu parlais si bien qu'une personne
chiens et même mieux que monsieur le
maire vous êtes bien aimable
mon dieu que votre panier sambre ah
qu'est ce que je disais ah oui mon
maître je mange hugnet à lui rendre la
vie facile et pourtant il n'était jamais
content pour un oui pour un non il me
donnait des coups de pied aussi
avant-hier et j'ai été bien surpris à
retourner il doit être fatigué
depuis ce mois arrête si vous permettez
je vais profiter de cet arbre quand lui
[Musique]
je t'aime bien tu sais moi aussi je vous
aime bien je fais n'importe quoi pour
toi moi aussi alors pourrais-tu prendre
mon mal tu devenir aveugle à ma place
qu'est ce que vous dites je te jure que
tu seras le chien le plus heureux de ce
monde je te lis dre quoi comme tu m'a
guidé la vue tu sais ça ne fait pas tout
le bonheur devenir aveugle à sa place
oui avait dit où peut-on m
tu as dit j'espère tu ne manges lui ai
d'abord dit non mais il a beaucoup
insisté
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites
vous allez vous ne vendez pas et voilà
pourquoi je suis tout seul maintenant
vous ne voudriez pas m'emmener
on aimerait j'ai bien fin aussi
qu'est-ce qui sent si bon dans votre
panier
c'est une fraise de veau mais c'est une
commission que nous rapportons pour nos
parents elle ne nous appartient pas
c'est bon j'aime mieux ne plus y penser
mais est-ce que vous m'emmener au moins
oui c'est souvent dire les parents
du contentieux est content avez vous
déjà un chien
oui mais il est malade en ce moment je
ne serai bon à rien on ne remet pas par
intérêt vous êtes de bien gentille
petite fille est sûrement bien je lis
aussi et vous devez également être très
raisonnable pour qu'on vous ait confié
une fraise de faux je vais voir si on
aperçoit les petites
[Musique]
voilà les petites qui rentrent en tirant
un chien au bout d'une ficelle
je n'aime pas beaucoup ça moi je sais
déjà où avez vous trouvé
et pourquoi le ramenez vous c'est un
pauvre chien qui paraissait très mal aux
répondants défend vue d'adresser la
parole à des étrangers
je vous salue bien madame et monsieur je
comprends parfaitement qu'il n'y pas de
place dans votre maison pour un chien
aveugle et je vais reprendre mon chemin
mais avant de partir laissez moi vous
complimenter d'avoir des enfants
si sage et si obéissante tout à l'heure
j'avais très envie de la fraise de veau
qu'elle vous rapportait et bien j'ai eu
beau prendre l'air méchant
elles m'ont dit la fraise de veau et
pour nos parents et ce qui appartient à
nos parents n'est pas plus chien moi
quand je rends compte deux petites
filles aussi raisonnables et obéissante
je ne pense plus à ma faim et je me dis
que leurs parents ont bien de la chance
je n'ai pas plaindre
ce sont de bonnes petites filles oui je
les grandes haies pour les mettre en
garde contre les mauvaises rencontres
mais elles ont bien fait de vous ramener
à la maison
mais comment se fait-il que vous soyez
aveugle et que vous alliez ainsi seuls
par les chemins n'est par ici outre est
donc
[Musique]
alors le chien comptant encore une fois
son aventure les parents l'écouté avec
intérêt et ne cachaient pas leur émotion
quant à moi j'étais entré au milieu du
récit et n'en étaient pas moins ému je
n'aurais jamais cru ça d'un chien vous
êtes le meilleur des chiens je ne peux
que vous reprocher d'avoir été trop bon
donnerait donc à la maison aussi
longtemps qu'il vous plaira alors
comment ça pour le chien une véritable
vie de chat lemaitre lui construisit une
niche luxueuse
on lui apportait ses repas qui était
toujours exquis naturellement il prenait
aussi de l'exercice les petites l'avait
promener dans la cour de la ferme en lui
expliquant tout et en lui faisant tout
sentir depuis il s'y promener seul aussi
aisément que s'il avait vu clair les
petites landes mais aussi quand elle
allait au village ou cueillir des
champignons
elle lui expliquer ce qu'elle voyait
[Musique]
y'a un gros nuage qui semble improbable
entre le chien leur disaient ce qu'ils
sentaient jeux sont un crottin de cheval
je sens aussi un lierre je suis sûr que
lui vous ne le sentais pas il rit y est
presque tout le long du chemin il jouer
à qui des trois irait le plus vite en
marchant à cloche-pied mais c'était
toujours le chien qui gagnait parce
qu'il lui restait tout de même trois
pattes
moi j'étais toujours un peu peiné de
voir le chien s'en aller avec les
petites
heureusement le soir quand il revenait
nous bavardions tous les quatre nous
avons fait une promenade bien
intéressante nous avons été chez le
boucher
j'ai demandé au petit d'acheter un
morceau nous pour toi
pourtant certains soirs le chien
semblait triste je pense à mon ancien
maître maintenant qu'il n'est plus
aveugle et qu'il lui faut travailler
pour gagner sa vie
je suis sûr qu'il regrette les beaux
jours où il n'avait rien à faire que de
se laisser guider par les chemins et
d'attendre sont pas de la charité des
passants je suis même bien inquiet sur
son sort car je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
au monde
un homme plus paresseux
[Musique]
tu es bien bête de te faire du souci
pour 1 m quitte à abandonner les pas
bête il est beau c'est la même chose
tant les gens méchants qui disent ça et
toi on ne te moquer du chien après mid
est bon aussi
oui et quand on joue avec toi te ne pas
nourrir les pour nous faire battre au
coin par nos parents comptent bien faire
encore hier soir ce fut pour moi une
cruelle révélations les petites me
trouvait méchant
certes il m'arrivait de griffer mais
c'était pour jouer je croyais être aussi
bon que le chien est peut-être meilleur
encore ouais mais à quoi bon être bon
aussi tout le monde vous croit méchant
tête alors que je décidé de frapper un
grand coup et de donner une preuve
éclatante de ma bonté
le lendemain après une nuit de réflexion
j'allais trouver le chien bonjour julien
bonjour chat on dirait que tu t'es levé
de la mauvaise patins
le matin quand j'ouvre les yeux c'est
toujours tout de même une mauvaise
surprise de ne pas y voir clair
justement je suis ennuyé que tu ne vois
pas clair j'ai pensé que si tu voulais
bien me donner ton mal je pourrais
devenir aveugle à ta place et faire pour
toi ce que tu as fait pour ton maître
shah
mais alors tu es bon il faut être
aveugle pour en douter au pardon tu n'es
pas pour tuer excellent mais je ne peux
pas accepter
tu me ferait plaisir tu ne t'en rends
pas compte
toi tu as besoin de tes yeux pour te
rendre utile dans la maison moi je suis
un paresseux qui ne se plaît qu'à dormir
au soleil et au coin du feu
ma parole j'ai presque toujours les yeux
fermés bof
autant pour moi être aveugle
[Applaudissements]
bref je parlais si bien que le chien
fini par se rendre à ma prière les
échanges de vues se fit sans plus tarder
et jean fut tout de suite récompensés le
chat est bon le chat est bon et moi
j'étais si heureux d'être bon que je ne
voyais même pas que je ne voyais plus
dès qu'ils lui recouvraient l'a vu le
chien nu plus d'une seconde
il fallait qu'ils avertissent quand un
vagabond s'approcher il devait aussi
accompagner les troupeaux la nuit même
il ne pouvait dormir que d'un oeil
toujours à cause des vagabonds et
également des renards qui rôdaient
autour du poulailler
quant à moi il me disait souvent sa
reconnaissance mais n'avait pas le temps
de me l'a prouvé simplement de temps en
temps il me faisait faire un tour sur
son dos et si les petites me prenait
bien encore sur leurs genoux pour peut
caresser
elle trouvait plus amusant de courir et
de gambader avec un chien elle ne savait
pas de jeu auquel ont pu jouer avec un
pauvre chat aveugle c'est pourquoi soir
que j'étais montée tant bien que mal au
grenier en cognant la tête partout je
croyais que vous étiez aveugle je ne
suis pas henry mais je t'es senti sami
ben hadj cissé moi mon ami tu plaisantes
je vais te manger à moins que je suis
aveugle
si tu veux le devenir à ma place je te
laisserai la vie sauve en outre je te
donnerai à manger je te protégerai je
t'emmènerai promener j'ai vite surtout
décident en toute liberté
oui messieurs dit nous vous me manger
bien entendu a alors j'aime encore mieux
de venir à bout
le chauffard à pépé lui je veux savoir
si on doit vraiment rien quand on est à
bol
[Musique]
abu ishaq eu de bons points à l'école
l'a de nouveau ici aussi n 1 du nouveau
le chalet plus aveugle c'est la souris
il l'est c'est une bonne petite bête
je vous la recommande sa grande île et
ne manquera de rien le ch a été très bon
et voyez ce qui arrive
il en a été récompensé oui enfin c'est
qu'il ya dix ans et la vie suivi son
cours les un certain jour mon chien mon
ancien maître excusez moi mademoiselle
ne faisons pas la charité aux gens
qu'ils peuvent travailler tout le monde
parle comme vous mais c'est terrible
qu'est-ce qui voudraient je travaillais
bonnes affinités
[Musique]
ce su parer ce je suis le maître du
chien que vous avez recueillis
c'est moi qui lui s'était massé cité je
mens repas amèrement quand j'étais
aveugle
bonjour vu pas besoin de travailler les
gens me donner à manger à coup sûr
c'était le bon temps
si vous n'y voyez pas d'inconvénient je
vais demander ma cécité à votre chaîne
hi leur passé au chant un jeu je vais
leur demander aux chats ils en bavent et
une souris je veux leur demander à la
chaux sais tu qui est en train de parler
avec les petites mon ancien maître bon
comme tu es ça m'étonne que tu ne lui
saute pas aux coups je lui en veux du
tour qu'il m'a joué depuis je suis si
bien ici à tuer encore meilleur que moi
ce n'est pas peu dire
je suis sûr qu'au fond de ton coeur non
je ne sais pas si je suis bon mais je
crois que je suis fidèle
qu'est ce que tu veux on ne se refait
pas oh regarde on m a repris sa cécité à
la souris et c'est la souris qui le
guide
je le vois pas la souris les si petit il
faut des yeux de chat une souris ne peut
pas guider un homme
évidemment c'est risquer la besoin de
moi part de loin adieu
chien serait il a besoin de moi j'la
besoin de moi
[Musique]